hey guys what's up I'm Hannah Dickinson
and I'm here hanging and banging a
cluster fest I'm just looking for good
food fun times and creative ways to
disappoint my parents hey what's up I'm
here with Ben I actually slept with the
Ben last year who never called me back
so what do you think that is did you
tell him your real name or did you use
the fake name that you told me just
before we started filming this and what
name was that bovis so are you single
what's up I am NOT single
what do you do finance for a tech oh no
that sounds great for me uh how much
mind you making yet oh I can't count
that high honestly are you single
no you guys we need to screen these
people before we talked about and are
you single what's happening no what does
your girlfriend do
I hope I'm not straight Oh what's up set
down over are you dating anyone no that
is a yes
are there any comedians here you want to
make Alice whew I'm gonna watch this I
don't want to say the name Jon Stewart
no Nick Kroll he's definitely not
watching I'm here with very funny
comedian Ali Siddiq how are you doing no
one that's nice I'm gonna say a bunch of
weird stuff tonight
what do you consider weird stuff cuz I
see a lot of weird I don't like I
have a sexy pregnant women I think that
might be a universal I don't know for a
lot of say that there's a lot of middle
light sleeping with pregnant women
well I look pregnant after a full meal a
slightly poor woman I mean we've eaten
and now with Jon exercise savea's ever
had a threesome
no oh yeah no like a nervous one like
you guys definitely like falling into
one I've been kicked out of a threesome
it's a long story
I'm actually here with Action Bronson
interested so what do you do for a
living
I'm retired what did you do before
what does Chef mean you deal drugs on
drugs are you single or what's happening
very single that sounds like an
invitation for me do you both work in
tag you look like a guy who works inside
how much money you guys make I make tech
I make tech money yeah but I don't know
what that means I make enough to live in
San Francisco oh all right I don't make
tech money what do you do oh yeah
barista I know a little bit better than
that
Urban Outfitters yeah I work for the
city that's worse than urban outfitter
where's your girlfriend I'm Sarah she
goes to a different school how long have
you guys been together what time is it
oh it's not my window but you might have
a little window of opportunity here I
mean girls revenge is always the worst
you know what I mean like I'm not
looking to get chopped up into little
pieces
you got some sunscreen on I can tell
you're a ginger you might need it I
don't know what part of your body would
you like to be rubbed down or I mean
protective just my neck and arms for now
something we covered otherwise all right
we get some really go with my hands you
wanna try to pick me up
[Music]